all right great think we're good to go
welcome my name is Yan and together with
Joel will do this talk about cloud it's
actually going to be a split talk we'll
talk about cloud notebooks first and
then we'll cover accessing and deploying
things to the clouds which we call cloud
objects in general it has already been
mentioned took the cloud we've seen it
in the keynotes and several other talks
so we'll try to cover a little deeper
topics here and jump right into cloud
notebooks first you've already seen this
this web interface probably where you
can access your files in the cloud you
have this dashboard and you can create
new notebooks of course and if we if we
look at at this cloud notebook here Oh
to refresh this that is open before the
internet book here very good it feels
very similar to a desktop notebook so
you have sections in here you can can
add subject subsections text you can can
format text as usual and of course you
can do evaluation so if we enter
something press shift enter it evaluates
it's all running in the browser there's
no plugging in salt it doesn't depend on
any local Mathematica installation just
just in the browser and the evaluation
is done in the cloud on the on the
colonel on the server side of course
this is not not brand new maybe maybe
you've seen this before so there's
support for for graphics for plots like
this the nice thing is now you can you
can resize this we have support for 3d
graphics where you can can generate this
plot and then drag it around to rotate
it and that's dynamically switching from
an email
representation first where you get the
absolutely faithful representation as it
would be in desktop Mathematica which
includes the the labels and so on but as
soon as you as you click it it switches
to a WebGL based rendering which is
pretty neat i think then of course we
have support for manipulates so if you
have something like this you can drag
the slider and when you let go it
updates the image of course so so that
all feels very much like like a
desktop-based notebook but it's also not
very new I think we've had this year ago
as well where we've made really good
progress in the last year is typesetting
in general and and one of the outcomes
of this was for example when you do an
evaluation after you get the result you
also get this suggestions bar where you
know you get suggestions what to do next
with the result which is I think pretty
useful especially for newcomers to the
language so that they can explore what
what what all there is or if you have
this plot I know it tells you she come
on I know you can add a background or
whatever and and you may like this or
not but but one thing they certainly
drove was was all the developments we
made in in terms of box rendering when I
say boxes I'm not sure if you know this
concept but basically whenever you you
evaluate something what you get back
from the colonel in what gets actually
displayed on the front end is is is
boxes and there's a box language that
describes everything you see on screen
so for example this you can you can show
this by pressing command shifty you can
see that there's that there's a row box
and it has certain certain strings in it
certain contents or if you if you have a
fraction it gets turned into
a fraction box and there's a very very
deep language for boxes to represent all
sorts of things that that you can see on
screen and and now the exciting thing
that happened during the last year was
to develop the suggestions bar
particularly we had to support a lot of
different boxes and what you can see
here is using just the native box
rendering implemented in the JavaScript
client so this is not this is not a
custom JavaScript widget but it's using
all the dynamic controls that are built
into mathematica into the Wolfram
language and using them natively on on
the web so we implemented things like
click button of course she can have that
or you can have an input field and type
in here we also added support for for
dynamic so if you have dynamic of X and
later you sign something to X it changes
the output up here you can you can do
that in a button as well I guess so now
if I click this button the value down
here updates I could also put it in an
input field or or whatever I want so so
this is the sort of thing we worked
really hard on and and one thing to make
that happen is one important step to
make it happen was to switch from
image-based output to this box rendering
output and some something very critical
to make that extra work is is line
breaking and all the different type
setting constructs that are present in
the box language so if you now enter
something like or if you get back a very
long number like in this computation you
can see that it that it's line wrapped
quite nice quite nicely so you get
doesn't overflow you get the digit
groups and this is all done in the
browser in the javascript javascript
based rendering so if I now go and
resize the screen this will this will
flow nicely
it of course gets gets more complicated
when you have things like grid for
example and you have different things in
there again it's laid out nicely this
would not be possible with an
image-based output of course especially
when you go and resize the screen and
also it works for input as well at least
at least this kind of line breaking so
if I copy this output from above and
make it an input cell I can now type
numbers in here and you can see how how
nicely it updates while i type so yeah
that that was a big step forward um and
and if you're wondering what why it's
why it's taking so long and what's so
hard about rendering notebooks in the
browser this is a big part of the answer
to get to get this mathematical iron
mathematical like line breaking and also
aspects of baseline alignment right in a
JavaScript based implementation I'm not
saying we're they're completely over
that that would be in our statement but
we're certainly on track and we have a
good framework now to work with things
like this um the challenge is that to
get this custom line breaking you need
to bypass a lot of what the browser
would provide I mean you know many of
you might know you can have a table in
HTML and it's very easy to write write
you can write HTML but but that would
never give you what what mathematical
typesetting provides so to make to make
notebook rendering happen in a browser
we need to bypass a lot of what the
browser provides and started a very
lower level so if you were to lik look
at the dome which is the the underlying
structure that the browser works with it
it looks really we are complicated and
then it won't seem very familiar so what
we actually have to do to make this
happen no it's not all visible on screen
but you know i'm i'm basically looking
at the underlying structure behind this
output here
and and what we have to do to make this
line wrapping happen is that we position
every single character at a particular
position on the screen so you can see
you have a 1 here 737 here 3 here and
they're all they're all positioned
absolutely with a certain left and top
coordinate in order to to position bits
on the screen where we actually want
them and to bypass what the browser
would do with them so it's it's not
something you would ever write by hand
of course but but the JavaScript that we
implemented handles this and another
challenge is of course that is not only
about math typesetting but we want to
support all these interactive controls
and dynamic elements so there's not
really any library that that would do
this for us if you're thinking maybe
math checks would support this or
something else that that wouldn't really
work for us because it it's not possible
to nest things in there as much as we
like and in the end they're also not
fast enough if you think about using
this for for an editor so rendering
boxes what as you type that that
wouldn't work with any of the existing
libraries so so once again the easy way
that you could think of unfortunately
doesn't doesn't work if you just if you
imagine you have a grid and you turn it
into this table there is a mathematical
function that the does that actually you
can export it to an HTML fragment but
but that would look completely different
so yeah those are the challenges that we
faced and particularly addressed during
the last year to give you a little
overview of what happened so far we have
this wonder can make this little bigger
so so this is an outline of the
evolution of the the cloud notebook
interface so far to give you an idea
that it's not you know it's more
complicated process than it then it
might seem and even if you just see it's
all
is a notebook in the end but there's a
lot of things going on in the background
I mean it probably all started with a
simple plain text editor and simple
image based output and that's something
you can have after a week of development
maybe but but then you certainly want
more I mean when you when you write
mathematical code you want some syntax
highlighting at least so you have to
move away from a plain text field and
then we used code mirror version one for
that and on the output side we added
support for manipulate and then 3d
graphics at least at the cell level so
that that was how things were about a
year ago you could have special output
special dynamic output but it would only
be really dynamic when it was at the top
level of the output cell if you had some
grid and in that great there was a
manipulate it wouldn't be interactive
anymore and and later we added support
for 2d graphics so that you can resize
them and have tool tips in them and so
on and on the outputs on the input side
we added support for more syntax
highlighting auto completions and and so
on that that's about the state were
about the year ago now as I said would
happen in the meanwhile is that we now
have a really good client-side
representation of boxes that allow for
more interactivity it still depends a
little bit on some server side
pre-processing of the boxes and I'm
going to talk about this a little bit
more later but what is also allowed us
to do is as I said we're using the same
technology to render content that you
type in the editor so even though it's
the input is still sort of
one-dimensional pure text it gets
rendered using the same technology used
to output boxes so that you get this
nine it is this nice line wrapping we
saw that's about the state we are right
now but we're really working very hard
to get to this where we have a native
understanding of boxes in JavaScript
without with much less pre-processing on
the on the server side at least and and
eventually we'll hopefully have
something like a box based editor but
you can also type superscripts and grids
and everything like that right right in
the cloud notebook to give you an idea
of what that means in terms of the code
it's it's been a yup big inflation of
JavaScript code so far so you can see at
the know where this is this is supposed
to mean JavaScript so so at the
beginning of this year you can see that
the JavaScript part took over the Java
part in in our code base and it's really
a huge amount of client-side code that
that gets executed as you render these
cloud notebooks in terms of the overall
architecture what happens is that when
you when you evaluate something of
course it all starts in the JavaScript
client where you press shift enter you
do some dynamic evaluation it sends a
cell ID or some arbitrary expression
through to the Java server in the cloud
and that expression just gets passed on
to the Wolfram engine to the colonel
running in the cloud and what comes back
is usually just just a box expression
like like this one here and then the
traveller ever takes that and persists
it in the note spoken in a notebook file
in the cloud and our idea at least is
what we're working on on very actively
right now is that what comes back from
the Java server to the JavaScript client
is is really not much different it's
just a serialization of this expression
into JSON it's just this JavaScript
object notation where it doesn't do much
with it but it just passes on row box
and then inside there is the fraction
box it's still pretty much the same and
then the JavaScript client has some
understanding of that and as I said we
were switching a little bit from from
from this approach we were still having
right now as in the published version
where that the server still pre
processes parts of the boxes but it
turned out for us that this doesn't
really help in the end it seemed like a
good idea in the start but in the end it
turns out there's certain things in the
boxes that really want to be handled by
the client because of dynamic features
certain dynamic options it really mucked
makes it much easier to think about when
everything is handled by the client and
it also makes the process easier of
adding support for new boxes because you
don't have to implement them on both
sides so so yeah that'sthat's we're
really moving moving to to a JavaScript
implementation of the whole box language
so what happens then when when this box
expression reaches the JavaScript client
is we built a a nested model of these
boxes using using a library called
backbone.js if you know it and and that
model then resolves all sorts of options
certain dynamic features and we'll be
using some asynchronous libraries for
that to make that easier and then
eventually it hits the view
corresponding to that model which which
renders everything into a dom node plus
some dimension information so in our
case it's it's trickier than just
producing Dom nodes but you always have
to keep track of of the size of things
and where to position things eventually
that makes it a bit harder and what we
are investigating right now is maybe two
to optimize performance further is to
have the views produce virtual Dom
representation using a library called
react if you know that so that we don't
manipulate the browser don't directly
but produce some representation
beforehand and then this library
provides an intelligent way to update
the browser Dom with the necessary
changes because it turns out that the
these Dom manipulations they
a real bottleneck of of of notebook
rendering so if you can reduce these
it's all going to be faster so so this
this is what what the active development
is is is basically all about it's to
speed up the notebook rendering and then
also dat editing process and and once we
have this solid foundation and we're
really close to that then we'll go into
more breath and support more notebook
box structures and to make it even more
more interactive further down the road
what we certainly planned to do is is to
have some API to make it easier to embed
note individual notebook pieces into
other websites and then also be able to
control certain parts of it to know
emulate writing into an editor or things
like that as I said even even further
down the road we'll probably have
something like two dimensional editing
like the box based editor and and
another big idea where we're still
having our minds is live collaboration
on cloud notebooks but but will only
start to think about that once once we
have this solid solid framework for box
rendering so that's that's about the
current state of notebook there are
cloud notebooks and going to switch over
to show for cloud objects thank you
so the Zeon mentioned my on you hear me
as i mentioned we're going to talk about
next cloud objects this is our system
for kind of representing your files in
the cloud and also making deployments
this is going to be kind of nuts and
bolts programming and if you were at the
workshop there's going to be some
overlap it's not not some of it is will
be new just the basic if you're familiar
with the acronym crud create read update
delete you know you want to know about
those things if you have persistent
things so we're going to cover those
topics for cloud objects and and look at
a demo and then we'll end with some
ideas for ways you can use these so what
are what do we mean we would say cloud
objects they are this is our you know
Wolfram research way of letting you
store your files in our cloud and access
them either in our cloud or remotely
other cloud systems have other models
for for file storage this is ours you
can ask the access them from anywhere if
you if you evaluate a cloud put sounds
just like put and it's it's a similar
idea what takes an expression and puts
it in a file well this takes expression
puts in a cloud object so there's a URL
based cloud object expression that got
returned from this and we visit that
actually i'll probably have to switch
users because yan does not have access
to my cloud objects can I clue these ok
I could make the permissions public and
I would be able to view that as has yawn
but
and I wanted to see this range of
numbers
so that this is you know a view of my
expression this is not particularly
interesting but there's more you can do
with this so that that just showed that
I can I can view it in the browser I can
also access that but but let's take a
look what what really happened when we
did this cloud put first of all a brand
new cloud object was created it was
assigned and identifiers this long
sequence of texts digits it has a mime
type that defines its behavior when we
click the link something happen based on
its mime type its mime type is a that's
basically a mathematic expression and
there are also some options on this
cloud object if you ask for yes four
options seeds I actually evaluate that
it's blue so it doesn't look like it did
so I asked for options of this object
you'll get an idea of some things that
can happen there's this meta information
there's icon rules and there's
permissions so there's you know there
are some things about these you don't
have with sort of ordinary files
sorry so
I'm missing one point that I wanted to
make on the previous slide and there are
there are other ways to create cloud
objects I pre created some of these so
this 1 i'm not using cloud put i'm using
cloud export and i'm specifying a gif
format so we're exporting this
expression and again it's creating a new
cloud object and it's got a different
mime type so this actually comes in the
browser it tells the browser this is a
gift and the browser knows what to do
with that and you know you start to see
that a lot of these export formats have
a natural home in the browser because
browser knows how to represent it and a
browser is going to be a good way to
deliver a lot of output from things that
we all work on I can generate a web page
kind of similarly there's a there's a
cloud deploy that will look out a little
bit more and I'm telling it ok there's a
there's a form at here this export form
marks it as HTML and so you view that
and it will be the HTML I can also
upload files through this copy file copy
file in version 9 where we didn't have
cloud would take you know with operate
on local files a copy file in version 10
you can specify a cloud object for
either arguments source or destination
so I can upload by starting with a local
file and saying destination cloud object
when I evaluate this on a laptop that's
uploading to the cloud if I evaluate
this in the cloud so a little bit of a
subtle tea but if you operate in the
cloud with a file you're actually
getting access to your cloud objects
your home directory has your cloud
objects and you can access them through
these file system commands without
wrapping it in cloud object with the URL
you just use the plane file name this is
a Rembrandt so
you can copy directory coming soon it's
a it's a it's something that there will
be supported very soon you can you can
iterate over it and sort of do it
yourself now but that's that's the
intent is to do the same thing upload
you can also you can copy a zip and
extract archive once it gets in the
cloud so we should talk about naming so
all the objects have this uuid a a
handle to the file some cloud objects
have a name you know if you if you
assign it a name then it has sort of us
you know past name like a like an
ordinary file so if I if I cloud put and
give a second argument of answer text
then you know the URL has an answer text
and there is a way to get the uuid from
the name so you could have the URL be
including the uuid or the name and I can
cloud get that actually I'm not cloud
connected here am i or am I so probably
yawns user isn't it that's not my this
is not my user uuid so
so I'm not going to try to fetch that
one I'm going to check who is logged in
and it is young so I will log out and
log in as a different as a different
user
it'sit's pausing on connecting so I
don't know if there's a problem there
alright well I'll move ahead at any rate
so you want you want to enumerate you
want to be able to look at your cloud
objects and this cloud objects function
is a way to enumerate it's sort of
similar to counterpart to file names and
you can give modifiers here cloud
objects with no arguments will enumerate
believe in your current directory but
you can also sort of filter on types and
I find myself doing this all the time I
create a lot of API functions so I want
to list just all the API functions
whether they're named or unnamed I don't
care what directory there in so I can do
that by specifying cloud objects of
actual I believe its type goes to your
API function so the cloud objects for
kind of enumerated you can enumerate in
a certain directory so there's there's
there's tools for accessing the you know
accessing your cloud objects this is
what I was referring to this type goes
to API function and there's there's
various kind of important types that was
those be the deployment so those would
include API function form function
delayed scheduled task notebook things
that you kind of want to give to other
people to represent you like how the
output of your work so those get sort of
special treatment in your rating and
there's a there's also a variety of
functions you know you pick a cloud
object and you can ask all these kind of
these questions you know does it exist
is it a directory what type it is how
big is it and all of that information
you can delete a directory or an object
all that information you can get back in
one shot with cloud object information
and it'll it'll tell you you know who
the owner is and think about when it's
when it was accessed and things like
that
and I'll just mention some of these
options so meta information you can for
decorate a cloud object with random key
value of not with key value properties
so i can i can assign to an object this
has the property that it's a you could
invent this this meaning that it's a
temporary cloud object that i want to
clean up later you could say this is a
cloud object that is for you know the
certain has this plays a certain role in
my application and so then I can do
queries for cloud objects that have that
that information key so there's kind of
a way that you can provide extra
structure to how you access your cloud
objects if there's not already sort of a
natural one like okay it just enumerate
all the ones in a directory that's
that's pretty clear but if you need to
you know add a tag to a cloud object
meta information as a way to do that
icon rules sure let's show that so
actually going to switch here and get a
cloud notebook
so we'll create you know it's all
essential answer object and we'll set
oh good question how can i make it
larger yawn ok just a regular that's
good
mmm so amount of information of you know
a little tag this as a temporary goes to
true and so you can provide an
expression there and now when I query
for the options on that it'll include
that if I want to just get that key I
can dig I can dig down sort of naturally
I could ask for all the meta information
keys or just ask for that one and so
this is a way to retrieve that
particular setting oh yeah to do it to
do a query that would be in the cloud
objects kind of enumeration interface
yeah so the icon rules if you if you
visit not that one but you visit unnamed
cloud objects they don't have names so
how do you know what they are we're
assigning icons to some of these that
sort of the thumbnail of the content and
so if you if you query you create and
see the the icon this is it's just going
to show you what you would see here and
there's also for the mobile app there's
an iOS icon for we're kind of
identifying it in a view like this the
sort of a thumbnail of the content
there's also permissions well
apologies I'm not native to this this
laptop i'll just show i'll just show
here there are permissions any way that
you can inspect on the object you this
one is created as a private one you can
assign permissions to particular users
and so you can query for that here
there's also an active flag for this
applies if you wanted to play something
and you know people are running your
your your API and all of a sudden you
discover some some bug and you need to
sort of put an emergency stop to it you
can set the active to false and it'll
stop being served but the cloud object
is still there you can go look at it so
you'd have to delete it or something
like that to sort of shut off a
deployment if if you if you want that
question
it's it it's a it should be matching the
standard for you know it's 128 bit
correct currently that's kind of what
we're limited to is if you want to limit
to a particular user it would be a
Wolfram ID user but supporting other
things is definitely a future direction
that we can look into and interested to
hear your thoughts on that the there's
no limit to the the size per se you know
other than maybe you know sort of an
operating system limit there's certainly
total limit for your account for your
cloud storage and that depends on the
subscription and kind of the arrangement
you have you know some of the upper ones
I don't think there is very much limit
but practically you know everything I've
been working with would be you know kind
of sort of similar to you know to
desktop size files I mean we're talking
about data sets if talking about
enormous data sets those just get
problematic because you have to move the
data into the cloud so you know upload
speeds and things like that would make
it sort of Impractical a private cloud
would be a better a better option if
you've got things like that now these
are all these are all good questions I
wanted to give a a brief demo of just a
problem in a way you can kind of work
with deployments so the problem at hand
we've got a photographic strobe or a
flash this is a this is an object used
in photography it dumps all of its
lights got the charges up capacitor and
dumps all its light in a fraction of a
setting question is in the settings on
the back it's got a fraction of full
power what fraction do we set it at so
it turns out that there's there's
calculation if the you can trust the
manufacturers published spec given a
guide number so it's a number
hundred or 20 or something like that and
a power setting in the form of 1 over 2
to the N so where we at if n is 1 then
we're full power but you might go down
to 1 30 second of the power we want to
compute the distance d that the subject
needs to be to correctly expose the
image so there there are solutions out
there you know you can you can trial an
error you can take a picture and look at
the back of your camera like ohh thats
that's not right and change change the
power settings and there are you know
you can buy a light meter which is
expensive you can buy a TTL flash that
does all this for you that's really
expensive we want to just compute this
distance set the power one step and it's
free so there's there some code for this
there's a power function some f-stops
we've got some code we work on this code
we're very pleased with it what we're
going to do is we're going to print out
a table of settings just a handy
reference table so there's a kind of
develop it we test it okay so for a guy
number of 155 at a power setting of 1
over 32 you know we were supposed to set
set the power in one sixteenth so this
is this is great we maybe have a
manipulate to kind of fiddle with this
okay you know whether there's a one hour
we want our subject at ten feet and
we're you know I want an f-stop of FF
over four so this is the proper fraction
so there's that's all good what we what
we dolton Utley like I wish I could get
this not to wrap these but we would like
this table so it's just telling it so I
can you know the way I we all want to
work with this is I know what f-stop I
want to use and I can I can choose that
I can come down to find the the distance
and I can just read right off of it what
I need to set my flash tube that's great
how can I get this in the hands of
fellow
photographers I can make a form so I
cloud deploy this and we now have this
automatically generated user interface
to to the function that I wrote that's
nice I don't have to know HTML carlo
right here and mcCargo have been working
on this system the increment is a
characteristic these are characteristics
of the flash that i'm using and i get
this image that i can go print so we did
a cloud deploy cloud deployed knows
about form function and this power table
this is a nice thing it cloud deploy is
going to pull in the definitions for
power table and any symbols that uses so
in this cloud object we have bundled all
the code we need for this deployment
when you ran it it loaded that code and
evaluated it you can also just make it
an API endpoint for some reason you want
to be able to build this into a mobile
app and have a different interface this
would be maybe an option for deployment
maybe you wanted this to not produce a
PNG maybe you realize most people
probably we can deal with PDF so you
change the export format PDF boom it's
producing something that somebody can
easily download and print so there's a
lot of flexibility for going from my
initial idea you know I'm developing it
and then I'm deploying and I've got all
kinds of options about how to deploy it
you know you can you can use a version
10 feature to go tweet hey I've got this
this thing out there here's the URL this
will show up on Twitter I like this this
connection we've got with the new
service connect service execute feature
and then finally if you want to track
the usage there's this function which is
still somewhat in development but you
can track the usage I'm passing in my
cloud object and it's giving me all
kinds of information about when that
deployment was accessed how many
you know times a day did people download
it or try my table you know maybe I go
and I went and shared it on a
photography site and I want to know
who's actually looking at it without
telling me because I want to know if you
know their improvements or anything and
so this is telling me you know calls
used and how many cloud credits it's
using this is a way to track my usage so
I'll just close with a couple of couple
of other ideas for ways to use cloud
objects we recently Wolfram research
launched this tweeted program initiative
and it's it's a little bit interesting
because it relies it uses the cloud so I
want to talk about that for a second so
this is the Twitter page for the tweeted
program account the concept may know is
you tweet at Wolfram tap and the body of
your tweet has is interpreted as code
and we tweet back to you what happens
when you evaluate the code so it's it's
a bot how does this actually work
there's there's kind of two parts to it
one part is some Wolfram language code
that we call the harvester and it is you
know periodically pulling do we have
tweets at Wolfram tap is there are
people tweeting at us then when it gets
one that's new it'll bundle that off and
make a URL fetch asynchronous call to an
API function that actually handles it so
you can have this nice fairly tidy
fairly reliable harvester that's just
asking is there new input when I get it
I'm not trying to do the evaluation
right there I'm farming it off to some
API function this has the effect that if
we get a lot of tweets at us we're sort
of using the cloud to you know we're not
blocking up that harvester to execute
somebody's coat even though its time
limited everything and even though you
know we're careful that you know the
users code this tweeting at us is not
going to crash our program this is kind
of nice it isolates it so that that
harvester just keeps running and keeps
sending okay here's this text there's
nothing harmful about the text that
they're going to we're going to evaluate
that and it goes off and you know
automatically gets assigned to some node
in our cloud that actually
runs it and when that completes it uses
service execute to do the return tweet
so this is kind of a neat way that kind
of integrates a lot of things that we do
so you could you could have the the
harvester doesn't right now but there's
kind of some not not very interesting
reasons that it doesn't but it could run
in a scheduled task so you could
construct programs that run in a
scheduled tasks I do this kind of
pulling and then farm at work to AP is
you can invert that structure you can
have an API function somebody makes a
request that needs to do some very
expensive calculation you know maybe
takes 10 minutes to run so it doesn't
make sense for any PID handles so the
API could kick off a scheduled task to
do the heavy processing in the
background and again those scheduled
tasks will sort of automatically get
farmed out to some some machine in the
cloud to handle a longer calculation
another thing that costs kind of
integrating some version 10 features
there are as entity framework in in
version 10 so we can combine that with
the Geo nearest and add and get end up
with a deployment that you can run and
say you know I was blindfolded and flown
halfway across the world and I'm dropped
here with a mobile device you know
what's near me so there's this there's
this kind of code that's asking you know
give me a table of all the gionee rest's
entities to my current location based on
this this geolocation so if I'm if I'm
running right here I can find out where
the nearest castle is this is sort of
you know sort of tunning cheek because
not all these are relevant with nearest
volcano but you kind of get the idea
there's there's a kind of some exciting
ways to integrate you know the desktop
capabilities with the deployments in the
web and especially if you couple this
with the idea of being will develop
mobile apps that call our cloud to do
some of these things
it's a it feels like we're kind of on
the cusp of you know some exciting times
that i'm interested to talk to anybody
about you know with what you would like
to do if you have existing code and
you'd like to you can see some way to
leverage and be interesting to talk
about how to how to kind of architect it
or get it in the cloud and they're in a
good way that's what i had for for my
you know what i wanted to share with you
so i'll open it up for questions either
for yon or myself